so as comedians coming up what are what
are some tips you can have as we land
this plane here because this is you know
this is all about just comedy in the
comedy game and what what are some tips
you could maybe share with comics ooh
some big tips all right cut down on the
booze don't go too hard I was uh here's
the problem with booze
do you drink not really good good for
you but uh just I love it so much and I
want to party I want to get drunk but it
kills your whole next day and I have bad
anxiety so when I'm hungover my anxiety
goes through the roof and I'm like you
suck you're gonna bomb this joke isn't
good you're trying to write you're like
it all stinks have you ever written a
joke in your life you kill yourself you
suck okay so all that [ __ ] and all that
comes out and I already have enough of
that sober so when I'm drinking it's
it's even worse but uh so cut back on
the booze just right right right even
you got nothing in your head just go
back to old tweets look at old jokes try
something onstage if you're doing a new
bit and you're kind of not doing well
with it just throw in three more
sentences real quick like what else
always stretch as much as you can don't
go out and bomb a ton but like what last
night I went on stage I was like I'm
gonna riff about Atlanta a little bit
maybe nothing will come maybe it'll be
humiliating but it's not the end of the
world so even when you're like alright
pull out pull out do three more
sentences just say [ __ ] it it's almost
like when you're doing reps and you're
on that last one and you can't do it but
you want to give up and your friends
just push it a little bit even if you
just get it up to here instead of not
doing it just that will give you some
muscle I think and it's the same with
comedy just push it a little further
just stretch it as much as you can until
you feel them like alright alright we
got it and if you do that enough over
years you'll become amazing because you
you a you're building something B you're
learning what it feels like to be
frazzled and and push that down you know
that feeling of panic when you're on
stage or like this is bombing abort keep
going and push your abort button further
away you know so you can build that that
Callos of like I can take a little bit
of bombing I can take it because I'm
such a wuss like people go you got so
many punchlines I'm like
I'm scared of silence I'm not this
brilliant writer guy I'm just I'm
punching it up so I don't have to feel
anything so yeah I always push it a
little further try to riff do that joke
that you're scared of doing sometimes
when I'm on stage I'm like a little
nervous out of my element I'm like this
isn't going as well as I hoped that's
when you try the new bit because that's
when you're the most vulnerable and raw
and it'll actually kick you into being
yourself it's almost like when you're
trying to when you're with a girl and
you're trying to be cool and funny and
it's not going that great just go well
this isn't going that great hold on let
me let me reboot here it just it's the
it's the thing your brain is telling you
don't do do that sometimes go towards
that [ __ ] it's like the del clothes
thing follow the fear go towards the
fear sometime and everything in your
brain say don't but that's when you
should and it makes the fear go away
ironically go into it lean into the skid
it's like that bill birthing he's like
when you're doing stand-up if you're bad
at going to crowd work go to crowd work
cuz you've got to learn it and the only
way to learn is to dive in it's like
basketball players I can't go left well
then work on going left the same thing
so this is all you know heavy inside
baseball Anil but just you know try it
it's right it's right down though you
know you got that weird Joker like this
is weird
try it let's go what's gonna happen this
is all prey that's the cool about
stand-up it's all batting practice until
TV or the special obviously you don't
want to use the audience too much and
just be like you guys are my canvas I'm
gonna take a [ __ ] on you and whatever
works I'll keep it because then you'll
be a bad comic so play walk that line of
being a pro killing giving them a good
show and working out your [ __ ] and
trying [ __ ] and that's a that's a good
line and I think some people respect it
they want to hear the new [ __ ] they want
to hear you working it out so yeah
that's my tid bit
this is tidbit good stuff man hey thing
I feel like I'm finally coming out of
this edible eye that when I asked about
comedy tips you like you came to life
Wow this is all I have no but it's fun
like we can just talk about comedy as if
it's our first
still yes that fresh I love it it's a
special thing and people are trying to
ruin it and it sucks but push on through
baby